it's like the first time ever actually
played happy wheels not house about an
intro oh she's Sparky
hello he has a what we want to explain
the air situation my my hair situation
first right out of the box okay so I
just spent Phillies just say is that
looks fine he just told me what was
going on talking about this right now
that's very most of them okay you're not
I don't know
I'm talking about it now anyway I'll
bleep out and we mix one whole thing and
put just the worst of images you can
pile in subtitles no no tell you what's
going on at all no please tiger squeeze
all right I'm doing it what is it text
elite I'd now like a ball can you see
ah yes actually and outside of my blind
floor that's good cuz if I don't wear my
glasses my fans will forget okay your
faces that you got perfect a friends I
know we're mighty faces I don't know
where the keyboard is a little bit more
more more more more left left
Oh up up lastly yeah oh you freaking did
it I got to the menu
oh nice there you go click it play now
yeah am i doing let's pick a yes pick a
character oh god damn it
yeah today that one yeah you did ha ha
did I get you scrolled around a little
bit hold on let me scroll down a little
bit
oh I don't know I fixed it ok stop it
okay so uh press face space no I okay so
now I want it alright clicks press space
to go now that you're actually on the
flash okay Oh press it hold it yeah
you're tricking go through the deed yeah
wait what this is one of those things
where you have to jetpack just the right
amount oh I love this and there's a
speaking of roof scape in our there you
go walking yeah yeah yeah yeah yes yeah
yes yeah yeah legs and crotch of goat I
did Megan that was pretty close though
you actually you're looking at the
finish right now okay alright we're
gonna do this pace a little bit more oh
you just oh the first bike you got on
Mike it's okay it's good you're not dead
you're not that open oh I thought I was
dead but it's all restart he's gonna
Davis look at Elvis huh whoo push it
push it hold it for a little bit Oh
push it this guy Sileo ah it's getting
worse it's actually going into his brain
in a second hahaha let's go you just ran
across the room oh my god I'm so sorry
do you feel the passion now I have a
complete misunderstanding of where I am
that's fun okay push it hold it for like
one second one like no do it again
another swine no that's a horse of
Icicle giving you you're actually
probably in a win now okay is that what
happened you were dead your carcass is
gonna be ticketed entry level I do want
to push for a second wait for like a
half second and push and hold for like
two seconds I believe in you make sense
yes one second half second off two
seconds back on hmm oh yeah hey let's do
less than a half second off less than
half huh oh no sorry yeah so okay so
start it out a little slowly and then
just you know gradually for like a
couple seconds what do you look at what
kind of gaze you give me right now I'm
looking at
what was that my balls I think yeah kind
of take up ah oh we should hold it for
like five seconds Oh
rotate to the left ah no keep doing it
what am i doing banging into moonwalking
time oh Jesus it's for like doing
it's amazing you said this awesome like
reindeer dance I feel your push space
was really good
great should I live I don't know push
face I don't think so no you're very
dead you're dead you dance your heart
out do you have hearts gone push hold a
little more ah
you almost ha you got to Chuck Norris
one buddy core gotcha Toby ha ha ha
doing it all right all right pushing ol
buddy well Google hold it it first
respond oh god okay push it hold it and
then push up like a puzzle other guys
there you die you die ha Walmart one
more to your jetpack just one to him one
by itself yeah owner yeah it's a
boomerang its go back to the old man
with you Oh
live I think my final chase hold it it
oh oh my god when Beauty pile of oh yeah
that's a winner
Oh what happened oh you hate it can I
look
yeah of course you deserve oh my god I'm
so tired much worries us okay okay back
on Jesse oh yeah put that all right you
just cheat aren't exactly called
sawtooth that's ironic cuz you saw with
one eye so it's probably make sense at
all
I've made a lot of sense you'll get it
later the vision thing you're a lot of
mental functions go away can you move
put him on the mouse please Jesus good
like that what is the left hand doing
Oh up up there no I don't agree
oh god I'm just kidding I'll be too soon
to the left down right down a little bit
to the right actually you have to down
up a little bit that's like it oh yeah
yeah well she's so good hurry this hello
say it you're back
this man is a police you jailed and
tortured your friends for no reason and
proof Tom for revenge
this man is a police forgive him or kill
him saw to what did he do like
Shadowhawk what am i doing you're
bouncing around like a how am i this guy
who are you segwaying on his kneecaps
this guy hit your mom with this Pogo cuz
your mama's don't money to pay her rent
oh I know what I'm doing or choice oh I
gotta keep it a literary oh you talk you
just did a Dyson I do you died and now
there's a pail of Segway die in your
bill Cooper death happens to all doesn't
take adults heaven will called saw down
oh I might have to up okay okay up
upwardly move okay you're hugging this
large guy jump-jump-jump you good to die
jump again go for whole tour while
jumping no no jump inhale forward don't
know how I get a little orange of all
the holy am push it oh you're dead now
you
why dad how your live actually but
you're not gonna be able to get out of
there haha
just how is that okay so let's hug this
man with the flowered Hawaiian shirt
she's looks mmm
cuddly ja ja ja no they don't it's my
fault it's my fault forward to keep us
in space cool watching just knock his
head off
ah knock his yeah let go ah okay keep
going
Oh too late your time you're googling
yelling you won what did I do
you googled a bunch of stuff googled
minor Dimond how so - uneven out yeah
yeah all right right up up up up down a
little bit down dadly yeah oh you get
good you get good thank you
oh you're old okay you're off you're
falling don't move oh is this a don't
move level hip - bad eyes but I want to
move preach it you are my bad if you're
painting the ground if you're not moving
oh I think you're doing one more time
this is make sure to omotte i says it's
called the longest don't move - so like
we'll see oh you don't you can move if
you have to do it but all i zo did you
died anyway you dying anyway
oh it's bad you picked the stupidest
possible level and order in me I'm going
okay you need to see every single one of
these episodes don't don't move in my
Bold form I thought would be a cakewalk
okay grab the Jenna push us push up
probably in the let go re pre sir
there's a dis delicate jet balance on
the edge of okay up in the space
incident ooh hold it hold it yeah yeah
mega pick leg the whole push my circuit
okay
okay so this jet glues itself to your
hand well as soon as you grab it it just
magically met the metal melts I see one
more time let's to do great alright up
and then space recently sure Oh
up the jet of space I'm digging a hole
do do they go hold it harder
what do you died okay okay all right
Hobson heyo they okay well you did
already
I guess you couldn't wait for me to tell
you to push up in space
you turn up that one this time yep I'm
gonna make it up face okay
I'm so sorry a little more all right
this time I'm going to go up in space
hold it hold it hold it hold it oh oh
did I make it pretty close but not close
the to go off his face we're we're gonna
get this hold it for a couple seconds in
Lego hold it hold up well I'm pretty
good I followed your instructions to the
letter it cuz of the letter I think we
did better than we even do anything
wursten let's do one more time it's
gonna be good this time I promise okay
often say it's up to you something
operated do it yes yeah yeah yeah I win
ah did I warn them purple tie up her
pants and you want thank you that's good
purple standing rub it all two games to
expose go ahead
go subscribed in also leave that half of
the boob purses good got a cut up